[Music]  it was really crazy Justin Timberlake  slayed the Pepsi Super Bowl 52 halftime  show on Sunday but there was one lucky  fan who really stole the show during his  performance the filthy singer ran out  into the audience  [Applause]  that's when 13 year old Ryan McKenna  whipped out his phone and snapped a  selfie with JT  [Music]  the moment went viral and Mackenna  immediately earns the nickname selfie  kid after the performance et caught up  with the teen and his dad Sean McKenna  who were at the game to support the New  England Patriots how's that selfie  oh it's awesome I've gotten so much like  stuff on social media and stuff it's  crazy  my phone's blown up as for selfie kid's  dad he's just happy his boy got to enjoy  the experience that was fantastic my son  [Music]